PopCap Games is a game company totally
focused on making games for everybody
breeds very proper it's about making
games that if you've never played a game
before you can pick up one of our games
and you can find that fun in that very
first moment and putting huge amount of
craft
into that experience that is very
approachable for everybody whether
you're four years old or ninety five
years old PopCap started in 2000 with
myself and to my friends our first game
was actually bejeweled which is still
our most popular to this day they
cruised along for the first few years
and started having huge success with a
couple their games and in 2005 when I
joined we were about thirty people
probably and and I think what the three
founders realized was that it was time
to sort of get adult supervision how do
we make sure we're getting the most out
of those eighteen people we were at a
stage where we were all just game
developers I was the CEO and I was doing
the business DLS we've got an amazing
offer to sell the company for 5060
million dollars it was crazy
and we decided wasn't right but when we
really were honest with ourselves that
was a forcing function for saying well
if that's not right we have to do some
things different or we're not going to
be successful long term and we realized
we needed to find someone who had some
experience being a CEO who could hire
some higher caliber talent who could
really help us steer PopCap to being a
much better more successful place that
could ultimately make more bigger cooler
better games
when the founders hired me to take over
at PopCap they were pretty brave by not
requiring me to be a games guy I was a
software guy I've been a software my
entire career before business school but
really the first thing we started to do
is look at taking control of our
business at the time this was a company
that just was a development studio and
they really had other people run their
business for them and my first challenge
was to build out the actual business
side of our business so sales and
marketing and distribution business
partnerships as well as just your
typical company infrastructure so HR
legal the the the plumbing that really
keeps the company running what he helped
us realize we had it was we had this
self-perpetuating Rd factory that could
have a really huge quality bar and break
even and then we could make money by
using partners and when he said is like
we can make a lot more money by bringing
in those business that right now are
through partners and bringing them
in-house so things like mobile
development retail console development
PopCap was acquired your and a half go
by Electronic Arts EA bought the company
for about seven hundred fifty million
dollars plus what could be up to 1.3
billion in an urn out that we're working
through right now it was I believe the
largest video game transaction in the
business to that date been a pretty
pretty crazy time watching this business
grow but it's it's been fun
you